Metro Redux is not as much about people
and about game systems as it is about
place it is a collection of two
Melancholy games each of them crushed by
the weight of a ruined earth both
adventures allow you time to choke on
their irradiated air time that makes you
wonder how the survivors of nuclear
warfare find the will to carry on in
both Metro last light and in the
refashioned Metro 2033 you scavenge for
ammo in the Metro tunnels underneath an
annihilated Moscow there are pockets of
humanity within these depths but humans
can prove just as deadly as the mutants
that roam the underground
it's possible you might have filled the
role of series hero Artyom and trudge
through this thick misery before but
various improvements to Metro 2033 make
it worth suffering again 2033 almost
feels like a new game given the newly
structured storytelling and a visual
upgrade that raises it close to the bar
Metro last light later set a
side-by-side comparison of the original
and the remastered 2033 provides some
striking differences in the way
environments and monsters look in the
way characters look and move and in the
way you interact with the game in some
cases I actually prefer the original
vision to its replacement such as in
some of the creature designs which were
scarier before but now objects cast
proper shadows and beams of light no
longer wash away the finer details and
characters don't stare with the same
blank expressions so stay clear of
trouble see the caravan to its
destination and come home soon you'd be
hard-pressed to find sweeping visual
changes in redux this version of Metro
last light it is the standard to which
2033 has been raised the more meaningful
difference here is the ability to apply
2033 s more stringent supplies of gas
masks and ammunition
conversely should you prefer last
light's original balancing you can apply
it to 2033 in either case choosing
similar levels of challenge between the
two games helps smooth their differences
making playing both games in succession
a heartrending and rewarding experience
that feels less like playing a game in
its sequel and more like playing a
single game that's been split into two
units
either way the dangers of Metro Redux
often prove terrifying in both games I
remember the first time a wings demon
sword in from above grabbed me with its
fearsome talons and dropped me to the
ground
this sudden loss of control is
frightening and the sight of the
scorched earth beneath you evokes the
perils of the surface clearly Metro
redux owes as much of a debt to survival
horror games as it does to shooters
since you spend as much time if not more
soaking in the darkness as you do firing
a weapon when the action heats up Metro
last lights levels are more carefully
constructed than 2033 giving
ai-controlled Nazis and communists room
to spread out and flank in both games
however I more enjoy the silent lurking
sneaking from one light source to
another to plunge the area into darkness
and then
knifing soldiers one by one whether or
not the AI is aware of your presence
it's certainly not the smartest you'll
see enemies might stupidly rush around
corners and right to their doom and
they're not always able to properly
navigate the environment
the people of the Metro speak in thick
Russian accents finding ways to amuse
themselves when not confronting horrors
some attempts to bring humanity to the
shadows are sadly more laughable than
they are compelling such as a sequence
in which you encounter and then carry a
little boy who looks freakish in away
videogame children so often do and
doesn't sound or talk like any child
would then again Metro Redux isn't
really about any individual person as it
is about the world these people are
forced to live in it's a place where you
must fear both the hideous mutants that
prowl as well as humankind and yet it's
only with humankind that you might find
safety it's the way you weave in and out
of danger and the panic you feel when
danger finds you that makes Metro redux
such an excellent tour through the best
and worst of a society and release
good you owe me one